he has to bring the same mentality not
be afraid to throw pawns forward like he
did in that previous game which
eventually gave him all those chances
and he calculated so well more
importantly he had a clock Advantage he
had an extra minute or two on the time
on the clock over Magnus throughout the
entire game and that really got him
close to Victory but in the meantime
repetition of game two of the day are we
surprised that Hikaru is going back into
this opening and this is where it
changes what we saw was the queen trade
but the other the bishop Pawn had
Advanced up the board and it looks like
Hikaru did a little preparation he
switched it up a little but we still
have an end game the Queens have been
traded off as Robert likes to call it a
queenless uh middle game because there
every other piece is on the board now I
have to say when the match started and
Hikaru after losing that first game it
looked like Mission Impossible and
Magnus knows that it's not going to be
easy with the black pieces but I'm still
surprised that Hikaru has an approach to
go for a queen trade so early on in a
win-on-demand game
very rarely works against Magnus Carlson
to get the Queens off and somehow
outmaneuver him and it clearly looks
like Magnus has done his research too
might as we can see do that Rook on D1
and what he wanted to do was bring his
own Knight to the center of the board
Knight D4 was a huge threat on the board
making it taking advantage of that pin
Hikaru continues to develop stopping
that threat brings the bishop to the E3
Square connects the Rook what he wants
to do next is push that Rook one step
ahead also signaling at a doubling up
along the only open file on the board
you've got Rooks bring them on the open
files again Hikaru has a big advantage
on the clock already starting to slow
down Magnus yeah maybe it's the nerves
he's phenomenal at it I mean he just
plays all these great moves and he
spends little time doing so and he often
seems Invincible until he plays someone
like Magnus Carlsen and I like what
Magnus has done because he pushes his
pawns And Trades off his Bishop for the
night but what he's been doing is taking
control of squares oftentimes we look at
chess and see tactics when we do our
training positions we're often looking
at how can I Checkmate my opponent or
win some material here he's making sure
that the Knight on C3 the only white
knight can't hop forward without a trade
and now the bishop on F3 won't jump to a
new diagonal because the pawn on H5
takes care of the G4 Square in the event
of a nitrate so I really like those last
two moves from Magnus Carls and he's
just taking care of his position he is
not taking it for granted every little
situation every little square it matters
be the Victor in Armageddon to take it
to a reset it's a lot to ask sounds like
a lot of winning yeah it's a lot to ask
against Magnus Carlsen but if anyone can
do it it is Hikaru Nakamura I think that
Magnus Carlson has this one under his
control especially after hikar's last
move he brings his Bishop to attack the
Knight on F6 but he's allowed the Black
Knight to hop into the center so I just
feel like Magnus doesn't really have
true weaknesses in his position it's
kind of simple frame to play now and
unless I'm overlooking something maybe
Hikaru has a hidden idea up his sleeve I
believe Magnus has this one under
control and he's ahead in the clock
qualified for event two in the Champions
chess tour 2023 that means we will see
Magnus Carlsen Hikaru Nakamura Wesley so
and Fabiano Carona in event two players
will fight it out as well in event two
neither of us played very well I mean
we both had some very strange moments
especially I think when I lost in game
two it was funny that I had to play Yang
Yi twice
um first in the winners bracket and then
he he managed to get through the losers
bracket after I beat him the first time
uh but yeah very very happy that I
managed to uh to win played in in almadi
the world championships and uh at
Fabiano we are super excited here in the
studio fans are super excited because
for winning division two you qualify um
but it was also interesting to play to
play some guys who uh haven't let's say
made their their mark on top level chess
yet uh also because you get you know
well I'm so familiar playing let's say
guys like Hikaru or Wesley or Magnus uh
it's still very chest Centric of course
in terms of my favorite guest well we
had some fun ones I I think Maurice
Maurice Ashley was very fun
um Levy Rosman who's a better known as
Gotham chess was a very fun one that was
very uh personal because we really I
think all of us opened up and we got a
good dialogue going on maybe those are
the the two that stick out most we also
interviewed Hikaru which was probably
our most watched one which was
interesting because you know Hikaru and
I have always I think viewed each other
as Rivals for a long time for you know
well over a decade I mean we were even
playing when when we were kids and he
was a bit older than me
this match is still going on Grand Final
in division one it must win for Hikaru
Nakamura we've had several moves on the
board bring us up to speed David yeah
several moves but huge developments
Magnus Carlson now I think has a small
Advantage if anything and the winning
chances for Hikaru Nakamura are minimal
you see it on hikaru's face right now
the game has not gone that well for him
the pawn structure has been clarified
there's been a couple of Peace trades
since we last talked about the position
and Magnus is in full control cruise
control at this point uh the Black
Knight has gotten some nice juicy
squares to jump into the black Rooks as
soon as they uh combine that will be the
end of the fun and I think this game
won't go that much longer uh someone
contradict me please because I want some
entertainment I have a decisive result
but I don't see it happening
unfortunately and uh I mean first move
that came to my mind was jumping in with
the Knight just because we looked for
forcing moves first this does gain time
hitting the white Rook the white Rook
moves I'm not sure where let's say it
slides across and now this Knight could
plan itself either now on the next few
moves on this nice Square I mean there
is an active night for white and that's
exactly what he's going for yeah it's
what he has to go for if he wants to win
this game and maybe the problem here is
that you're not quite in time for white
if you had one more move to double up
your Rooks now and infiltrate the black
Camp then great you might be able to win
but to hear Black can neutralize this uh
by bringing his own Rook back and
sliding across just one trade of Rooks
is enough to ensure that White's Rooks
never ever get into the black Camp it's
important as well that uh in a line like
this one that the Black Knight is on
this Square because after Rook takes
Rook the Knight jumps back to defend
everything and here if all the Rooks
disappear symmetrical structure white
will never win this game uh he's going
for it and I think the safest at least
is to go back with the black Rook maybe
Magnus contemplating going more
ambitious no he chooses a safe approach
I was gonna say you could deliver a
check but why bother you only need to
draw and uh once The Rook lands on d8
Karu is gonna struggle for winning
chances
for the idea of getting all the pieces
off the board and an end game with just
the knights it looks like it's going to
be the white ones that will need defense
defending once the Knight comes back
into action uh after the Rooks are
traded off we all want the Armageddon
but this that looks like a far off dream
right now
yeah distant dream and uh okay Magnus
takes back with his Knight a pair of
rocks and you played B6 hoping to kick
now Rook takes Knight is available for
white because when the Knight takes on
C6 for white that is a fork no matter
how black recapture so and that's the
one thing Magnus look out for he has
successfully done that uh he is not
going to fall victim to such a tactical
shot we'll save the day and at the very
minimum instead he just improves his
structure he pushes his Pawn forward
Robert it's a bunch of your ideas kind
of combined he wants to keep this one on
tap for later I'm not sure what the
direct threat is but at least it's at
least tricky for Magnus to keep control
over both sides of the board on the G5
Pawn keep that Knight honest but you
receive magnus's last move he slides his
Rook over to C8 about the clock times as
Robert mentions as well this one is not
looking very promising right now uh I
still don't think white should lose with
best player I think you're okay here
despite giving up that pawn for not too
much but uh Hikaru how does he at least
ask one or two more final questions uh
your plant on the board yeah that night
kicked back as soon as you have to start
retreating oh look at that that is class
that is just a whole different class you
know he doesn't want to move that c Pawn
creating weaknesses in the center
instead he liquidates the queen Side by
advancing the other pawn and now the
Rook will slide back creating another
weakness for white down on the a file
that A2 Pawn this is why it's called the
Magnus touch yeah impressive play Hikaru
meanwhile with a really creative night
Retreat he's holding things together and
I'm not sure Magnus wants to actually
rush and recapture that white a pawn
because there might be an annoying night
jump okay he has gone in now White's
Knight is going to go over watch out for
some Forks some checks but no Magnus
steps out of all the problems all of the
tricks and hikaru's night is caught in
two minds if it goes forward and takes
upon Black's root gets active snaps off
the white A2 pawn and unfortunately you
have to make a decision your car only
with two minutes needing a win but now
Black's Rook is active and
that's uh still nowhere near a win for
weight he looks annoyed Hikaru Nakamura
hope is running out here is the
tournament trophy that uh probably
Magnus Carlsen will win Champions chest
tour 2023.
oh oh
that's that moves almost as nice as that
trophy he just gives that pawn where two
white pieces can take it and now he's
saying if you take with the King your
king lost contact with the pawn that's
behind on F2 thank you very much if you
take with a pawn black springs for an
outside pass pawn and some night checks
I wasn't expecting that move I was
listening to you Kyle and suddenly I saw
them who played and I was just taken
aback that is beautiful tactical
awareness from Magnus Carlsen he is
really earning this Championship is he
finishing off In Style Hair Magnus he is
and I love Robert's reaction because
every true chess player when they see a
move like that it's like oh just oh yeah
you gotta appreciate it and it's what we
call an invisible move when uh you land
something on a square that looks like
it's protected multiple times it looks
impossible but uh often that breaks the
coordination in the enemy Army and
looking at the bar yeah he's got a lost
position and uh he knows it
unfortunately suddenly too many problems
that white C Pawn is about to fall off
with a nasty check that black H Pawn as
Robert pointed out running down the
board racing down to promotion soon
actually it's almost resignable gotta
say not just that there's another
problem the Knight can jump into the
play by giving a check to the king and
really creating all kinds of forks and
attacks just amazing board Vision here
by Magnus Percy breaks on the queen side
and then on the king side sacrificing
the pawn and this just looks like we
have a result we have a winner Magnus
Carlson takes it he wins the air things
Monsters the very first event in the
Champions chess store 2023 we do see a
smile on his face and what a battle it's
been and what a fight Hikaru Nakamura
has put on